today on the true Jodi podcast make the
count Bisping 1 ha ha - ha he's not the
oh it's a nickname right
you love Sesame Street he is a former
UFC middleweight champion general UFC
legend and so the Godfather of British
MMA general Amin and we were lucky
enough to be sponsored by UFC 3 who
bought you the podcast
thank you for success and lovely in
today's show the sponsorship would like
us to talk a little about the Ultimate
Team you can make and for that reason
they asked you a question how many
people have I got you get you get four
in your I'll tall so that's that's a
nice roster you guys I'm gonna go for
like my four sort of favorite sort of
fighters nice probably BJ Penn yeah he
was sort of one of my first big ones I
liked lyoto machida yeah just to be
clear this thing isn't in here this is
gonna be really upsetting look Conor
McGregor why but yeah he's got two
titles yeah and finally Michael the
count Bisping yeah it's quite a diverse
team you've got that yeah you got a
striker
once Hawaiian yeah one's Irish one sort
of Japanese Brazilian yeah and my
compass makes for amazing kinds of needs
to know where Mike Bisping was born
apparently he was born in Cyprus wasn't
it yes Cyrus yeah Nicosia
yeah that's variety I don't think what
snake is here but it was Cyprus if you
have in Cyprus I haven't no should we go
an extra anyway Iran
the point is that you can build an
ultimate team now on either as cool UFC
I do like the idea of sort of like
couldn't super come he's got a tag team
eventually that'll be such a good one
for free year yes I'm the Slayer you can
do that you yourse e3 thing where snoop
dogg commentate so quite idea he is
sending us the UFC fight night at the o2
so key aware good leo in London you have
see three countries that is gonna be a
great one we have good people to go with
I would just been told I can't we can't
say on the
that country usually hung out with it's
not calm and at the same time we've been
told were in a row full of youtubers Oh
spirit does so if we put one of our
guests on either side of us just a
buffer zone now we do enough to talk to
them that we thank you once again extra
space between us and other YouTube you
bought all the seats so we didn't have
to be around them at the same time
thanks for oh f that's really close yeah
thank you
ei his podcast I'm a [__] dude fun
there thank you suppose Ryan Ryan Ryan
Brian yeah thanks but is this close
enough can you do yeah I already haven't
got a I just wanted it sure yeah
absolutely yeah you're not strict agenda
on what we're gonna talk about yes I'll
I'll be watching you since the Ultimate
Fighter right right okay back in the day
do one like yeah well thank you very
much I appreciate that now remember when
you but like Ross pointing the things
yeah yes also Ross am I used to fight
with Ross back in and down Cage Warriors
and Russ is he carries a man I don't you
know like them a lot yeah yeah sure so
Ross point him you know he's a good guy
but we'd be at Cage Warriors and both of
fights not against each other and he'd
turn up and he'd only had like three
fights and let the car park or whatever
on the way is in Ross's leg was like
even more game than you yeah no yeah no
bus is like it says a real fire bus was
always that guy so yeah god bless him so
I remember actually looking at that
series you were the first guy in the
history of the USA from England to prove
that we could really do it it stay there
I know those a few of the lads you're
sure you stared at that top level the
longest more than anyone and you've won
the title yeah it's cheese everything
you've got to achieve in this might and
I'm looking at you're thinking in the
last couple of fights when when you're
lost sure you're in you're in the cage
and you you handled it a little too well
almost like it was like well well well
yeah absolutely so the GSP won
I actually told the cartilage in my ribs
the week before the fight it was the
final training session we should have
done the sparring session this sounds
like an excuse I didn't talk about it at
the time because you know you just
sounds like you're making excuses but
the reality was on the Friday before we
flew to New York you know Dean I'm a
singer you know that yes yes the Dean
was out there he was helping me a little
bit and he's showing for a double leg
takedown like his life depended on it
Remy across the Octagon I went down and
landed on top of my ribs generally that
would be fine but she's all right now
I felt something ripped so I couldn't
move I couldn't rotate couldn't do
anything so I got to New York and I was
having treatment on it every day it was
it was an absolute nightmare so people
said to me they said there you look too
look stiff in their mind yeah I was
stiff for very good reason normal self
ya know cuz I told the College in my
ribs but it was a big fight you know a
lot of money on the line so and you know
as a phony fight of your life yeah for
sure it was yeah and as a fighter you
still think you can do it you know and
yeah it wasn't my best performance it
didn't go my way but not taking anything
away from George god bless him good for
him he got the job done but then the
next one yeah you know was that [__]
you know okay whatever you know I'm
gonna make some cash just lost my bout
you know it doesn't get any worse than
that I've lost about so [__] outgoing
you know I went I went to win but if I
ever don't win [__] do you feel like
there's another fight in you
oh absolutely there is but I feel like
there is but I don't know if it's the
right thing to do
constantly wearing it people ask me that
all the time I'll never give a definite
answer and that's not because I'm you
know keeping people in suspense is
because I don't know you know I'm
working on a lot of other things now
it's ad the Octagon I've managed to set
myself up in a few businesses and this
and that and I'm doing a bit of acting
these days that's cause relics and like
yeah yeah
I've got a really good agents we've got
a few acting projects coming up I
literally just came from Atlanta I was
filming MacGyver out there always the
bad guy and you really only learning
McLean yeah my name is Lani yeah check
it out you haven't seen is really good
accent stuff as well part of made you
change your accent yeah I do yeah of
course yeah yeah you know I don't think
they won't clear that all accents in
Hollywood movies so we've written a few
scripts if you're interested oh really
yeah yeah you know you got to do that I
did an audition actually a couple of
days ago in a New York accent yeah
[__] terrible
oh my send it to my agent and he didn't
even respond okay okay the performance
was good but yeah the accident wasn't
bad but I think I sounded like I was
from black pottery cause like that I was
meant to be in New York so get over here
but yeah I've got a like rock called :
yo right now
is this someone if you were gonna do a
final fight you think it would be
fitting for you a trilogy fight end yeah
I guess I mean that certainly makes
sense but for me I was supposed to fight
with shard here in London and you know
whatever it may be you were for sure dog
yeah absolutely absolutely I wanted to
fight him because you know over the
years you know I've definitely been a
little controversial shall we say and I
wanted my final file even though some 39
now I'm definitely matured in the world
I used to be an idiot I'm still bit of
an idiot but I'm I'm less of an idiot
these days and I wouldn't want my last
fight to be you know at the press
conference talking shared and all that
type of stuff I'd rather put my best
foot forward go out there Faisal my
respect carry myself with class and
former chubs in as well yeah yeah he's a
former champion before before as well
and I have a lot of respect for him so
you know that's what I would like in my
last fight not go out there and you know
like an idiot basically out in the final
fight that's not what I want
be remembered for is there a party other
things in your head as well because
they're both very dangerous lads like
rock called unbelievable in my opinion a
great fight Oh
he's a total very good total dick job
ace but it's like if I'm gonna go in
there and I might lose I'd rather my
toes against Rashad and I can live with
that well the thing is well I mean you
can't top what I did to him at UFC 192
my first round I took his belt it
doesn't get any better
such an [__] I kind of don't want to
give me the chance either he hates it so
we were going back and forth on Twitter
the other day you probably saw it and
he's like sand the conch at Mike sand
the contract I'm like what contract what
are you talking about I said okay show
me your contract scribble out the
another compensation show me the the the
location update the the city whatever
the arena I said you know why you can't
can you because there is no [__]
contract so stop talking [__] after say
my my favorite title win of all time is
yours
oh I remember I set the alarm two
o'clock in the morning as everybody yes
that's what I used to do cooling down
the stairs wiping the sleep out me I and
literally the ring walked or on or
whatever right you're coming out and I'd
be honest through here like I didn't
have a doubt years of fighter but
Rockhold had been so good
sure absolutely absolutely I was one of
my favorites as well I mean so and
obviously very wide man and before
before I'm over you so I'm like this guy
is the guy who's gonna run the division
for a long time that's what it looked
like and when you could see that them
Brogan's calling out the mistakes he's
like he's dropping that high yeah wide
open and when you clip them and put him
away it was like you could tell it was
like [__] I'll just the site this guy
really yeah well well the thing was idly
sparred with him like I don't I was a
few years before they kidnapped Orange
County he was in town and you know we
got to get the respired and the smaller
session you know they went my way let's
just say like that and then I was on a
TV show in New York and it was an MMA
show part of me too much water and
they Rascals know you were called spar
together recently and he was a
Strikeforce champion at the time they
said how did that spy recession go I
said well you can't talk about sparring
sessions there but let's just say the
unofficial Strikeforce champion so
that's what I said and that pissed him
off big time so then me and unifies him
in Australia and I you know I handled
him aspiring but of course a fight is
very different and he got the best of me
that night and God bless him but I
wanted to fire him again because it's
like I've been in there with you twice
you know I know I'm not out of my league
you know so to explore so something was
yeah yeah and then it was I was filming
trooper Lexington runs oh I had it
trained at all and I got the call and I
wanted it's out family entire life you
know so I wasn't gonna turn it down but
I went for a run so as soon as I found
that was a whole [__] [__] [__] I gotta
get in shape so I immediately went for a
run
and as I was running I was thinking this
is just typical I wanted a title shot my
entire life
I get it on two weeks notice he was
training for why I mean I thought I'm
destined to fail you know what I mean
it's just so typical of my career and I
called my boxing coach Jason Parillo and
as I was running you know he he made me
feel positive and by the end of the run
I was like okay let's [__] do this
and I flew high I still have to finish
triple ax had two more days of filming
flew home off the airplane straight to
the gym two weeks and yeah there you go
the lasting impression I've got are your
fight is your and your family which I
thought was a really good moment like a
nice moment for you half but yes and
Perillo but the reason he did that is we
talked about the left hook he called the
left opium fact on Rockhold's instagram
he was doing this thing where you pulled
these cables whatever and even doing
that he was pulling his hand back here
and the hammer was low and he has his
chin up in the air so we drilled the
left hook over and over and over so you
know that wasn't a fluke we looked for
that so then when I landed it was like
there you go No
and that year that you had I don't know
if there's a us a fighter who can say
they've had a the three porn in the air
of silver Henderson and rock called it a
higher quality that was a hell of a run
yes it was sometimes people talk about
John John's run that I always say that
was a [__] run yeah yeah no it was a
good it was a good win it's weird
because you know I had to put downs of
my career I know that and you know I
never accepted defeat I always wanted to
be world champion and to be honest I was
proud of myself because a lot of people
get to number one contender status and
if they lose they kind of disappear
because it's hard to do that and I got
myself in that position like three or
four times
you know I'd lose the number one
contender matchups and then I have a few
against another one contender again I'd
lose that so I just kept trying but
that's why after a few fights that when
I when I said I'm going nowhere I mean
I'm not giving up you know and yeah
there was a few times well almost even
as a fan I thought I don't know if it's
ever gonna happen for him like hey same
here I mean I'll be honest you know I
mean I work or psy was always gonna try
but I kind of in some ways resigned
myself to the fact that alright maybe
I'm not gonna be the champion but I'll
still love doing what I do still love
you know I'm a martial artist I love to
fight get paid good money for it and
that's my life that's my job you know so
I was still happy doing that of course
I've never given up on it but yeah there
was a part of it I thought well you know
I'm towards the end of my career maybe
he's never gonna have felt like as a fan
of you that the penny sort of dropped a
little bit when you'd be Anderson it was
like this yeah I love that level now our
greatest of all time yeah yeah yeah like
there's nobody I can't be if I can beat
him sure sure was that a mental thing
for you you know what I kind of was I
mean it wasn't necessarily that exact
thought but it was you know I was
working with Jason Parrilla for a number
of years and it takes a long time from
what you're doing in the gym to
transcend to a fire you know like we
just did some pods with varrick a size
zero we just did some passes that just
cuz he did it under paths you can't do
that in a real-life situation when
someone's moving around and the throwing
punches at you and this and that so he's
one thing to do on the pads it's one
thing to do it inspiring but then to do
it under the bright lights
against a world-class opponent
very different so it takes time you know
and it was just all starting to come
together around that time you know that
feel natural for you is that something
you feel always been quite good I like
that
that caught that physical coordination
and knowing because when I remember
you're on the map with ksi and he's like
what is my hand go yeah yeah yeah you're
just straight well to be honest I mean
of course I'm doing it for a long time
and it's like anything the more you do
it the better you get but to be honest
when I was younger I wasn't an athlete
at all you know I was actually you know
when you're at school and they picked
football teams yeah you know the two
best players pick the football change to
go I love him I love him I love him I
there was always like me and a disabled
kid at the end and they'd pick him I'm
like what the [__] come on come on I'm
not that bad as so yes all hope might
say again you give us all how ya stopped
even up because I've seen the
documentary isn't that yeah you weren't
shredded as a young lad let you seem
quite thick-set yeah yeah you've
developed as enough you mean early my
MMA days in two days and you're very
like full-faced yeah yeah speaking as a
full-face so I started martial arts when
I was eight years old that I was totally
obsessed to it and that was my life and
I didn't pay attention to school I
wasn't interested in that and you know
obviously I regret that now as a grown
man you know education is very important
left school at 16 dead-end job after
dead-end job living in a small town not
a lot going on there do you know what I
mean and that's just kind of what people
did in my mum and dad you know great
people love them to death but you know
they weren't particularly career driven
or anything like that they didn't
encourage me to go to university or
anything you know you know it's just not
it wasn't our family you know and we
weren't that type of family
unfortunately love them to death don't
get me wrong but you know so I left
school at 16 and it was just dead end
job after dead-end job and I put weight
on and I was stuck in a rock we were
teaching at one point yeah I did you see
that's actually what got me out of
martial arts because I went into my
friend's house one day and he ever set
decks I was 16 I thought it was the
coolest thing and seeing him alive I'm
very much all or nothing you know what I
mean I was obsessed with martial arts I
saw that but wow
and I just got born right into that
anyway as I say shitty job you know
living with my girlfriend
she died not training anymore I did I
put a ton of weight on and I was
thinking this is this is this is what
life's come to you know and I was kind
of disappointed kind of depressed and
there was a guy that I worked with in
this factory and he was like even my
supervisor he you know I worked with him
day to day and he'd always say Michael
you only told you got or kid you know is
this what you want to do for the rest of
your life I said no of course has done
he said well you need to think about
what you want to do while you're young
enough and try and do it so you got me
thinking and again you know that's not a
lot one little thing that changed your
life and I thought about it and I
thought about it and one day I went up
to him I said Mick I figured it out what
I'm gonna do and he stopped what he was
doing he walked off you guys oh yeah
tell me and he thought I was gonna say
like I'm gonna go to college and I never
studied to this and I said I'm gonna be
a professional fighter and he was like
oh my god you're a [__] [__] isn't
it MMA you know was virtually
non-existent and this and that's and
then I tracked down my old coach and
just kind of went from there you know
but that's not like a natural decision
to make
so you're someone who's what you're
described is like a dead-end job yeah
you're not particular happy in your life
it's not very often people go I'll make
this harder and get hit in the face and
like you know have someone try and break
my arm every day yeah why well I didn't
go to school so I know how many
qualifications you know and rightly or
wrongly I knew I could fight and I was
always that kid growing up and you know
what I'm a bit of a brawler yeah I was
yeah definitely even in the UFC you come
across as more game than anyone else
yeah you know yeah I mean you know it
was always the older kids yeah I was in
the third year I was batter in the fifth
years and you know I was a little [__] I
was a low [__] you have so much in
common
yeah I'm sure heard the story about you
were sleeping in the car someplace yeah
and so sorry I drag down to not to give
on a Monday and I said that's all Friday
and you know yeah there's sometimes it's
tainted being me sometimes instead of
his house sometimes I'd sleep in my car
I remember I was sleeping in my car and
it was middle of winter it was freezing
and woke up and there's like this much
snow on the car and I couldn't get out
cuz it all froze and not me Ron you
gotta get
then go to the gym and train and stuff
so you know it all paid off in the end
but I remember because we had two kids
as well my wife god bless that was super
supportive because we were already in
debt you know we're already borrowing
money off her mum and dad all the time
and my mum that didn't have money to
lend did you feel like quite low
self-esteem at that point because like
when you've got kids and you're not
providing for them the way you want knew
it was and so I said I was gonna do this
she had faith in me she said I know you
can do it and I remember I was sleeping
in my car on the phone and she called me
up and she you know she was she was in
tears
Michael got all these bills got no money
and stuff around for my [__]
I said don't worry babe I'm gonna book a
flight soon I'm gonna book if I seen the
promise so yeah you know just kind of
went from there so it's not been an easy
ride boy but it isn't for anybody it's
not a unique story most guys that fight
you know you all right some of them you
know they do it because they're good at
it but most of them most people fight
because they kind of forced into that
situation not forced but what they're
it's kind of their destiny some ways
because you know that's the hand that
they're dealt its necessity in that
sense they have to fight because they
need to earn money else you know and you
know I mean he talks a lot of our
destiny we've been talking about this
Lily oh yeah do you believe in like your
path has chosen before you warp it or do
you believe it you can decide I'm not a
deep person like that you know surprise
surprises but not really but but I kind
of is my desk yeah yeah yeah I mean I
did believe that I believed in myself
and you know when I was younger I wanted
every single martial arts tournament
ever ended every single one and you know
I had gone into 12 2014 in the sixty's
win them all and then I go in the
analyst and I get like a silver medal in
that do you know what I mean
so I was always very good and then on
top of that I was you know a little tall
rack I was getting into brawls there and
you know so I knew you know this was the
right thing for me you know with my
martial arts training as a kid and this
and that and I knew I had what it took
but there was no money in it back then
and everyone said if you're getting into
MMA for money you're making the wrong
you're wrong choice
that is the only reason I mean it but
yeah fortunately paid out what did it
feel like when you got your first big
check and a lot of the problems went
away and they were to tell the missus
like everything's all right so I was
there I wouldn't Hilton fire and that
was in June and you don't get paid a lot
for the ultimate fight you know of
course it's a platform and it gives you
a chance to go off and and become
something you know I think that the pay
for the over fire was five and five so
ten thousand dollars but then the
exchange rate was two to one so you know
and then you pay tax you know so I came
up with about 1500 quit mother yeah you
know a lot of that got pitched up the
wall in Vegas as well as so came out
with not much money and my next fire
that was in June my next fight wasn't
until December and you know I'm in the
UFC but I'm [__] more skin than I've
ever been you know what I mean
and I'll never date a compliment one day
he was getting close to Christmas and he
just called me up out of the blue he
said are you doing for money Mike and
obviously I'm a proud man says yeah yeah
yeah I'm good I'm good he said [__]
he said you can't be good
I'm gonna send you a check and there
sure enough you know he sent me a check
for $10,000 which is completely out of
the blue and then I had my fight UFC 66
against Erich Schaefer and I'm knocked
around the first round and I went
backstage and I'm getting changed and a
girlfriend she flown out by herself was
my wife now she she was site understands
completely by herself up in the
bleachers and Donna who works for she
said Dana wants to see you backstage and
I'm always in trouble some of our [__]
what have I done
why does Dana want to see me and I went
backstage and that is it here there you
go handing me an envelope when I opened
it up and Barnes for $50,000 with the
tax already paid on it she was like
$80,000 and I've never seen that kind of
money before I've my wife was in the
stands ran out I split up I said look at
this cuz we were [__] bro back then
you know always brings a tear to me you
know
maybe a pro to look that's it yeah and
then from that I just got better and
better
yeah and you know to be fair
Danny kicked the policies coming as well
you know so you know he's always been
more than fair what so generous what's
it like when you get that call from
someone like then away because it's not
like it must you know it's like the same
as if we got that we get a call from
someone who wants to make a massive
video with us isn't like that yeah yeah
change people's lives
yeah not for sure we can for sure I mean
like he's great
they don't have a really good
relationship you know he we deal reach
of a lot of money you know doesn't go
through my manager he calls me and stuff
you know ee ee is who he is and he
sticks to his guns and you know where
you stand with him but I really respect
that about you know what I mean he
doesn't sugarcoat it yeah a lot look
because like he built a lot of the the
UK fan base off of your back like
without you
I mean you've carried so many cards over
here for you you know and I'm not saying
this trying to sound humble for the sake
cause I'm on a podcast but people say
that all the time but honestly if it
wasn't me there would have been someone
else you know to me I'm proud of that
and I appreciate you saying that but I
never get too carried away with stuff
like that I think okay maybe but if it
wasn't me there would have been someone
else there'll always be somebody you
know people talk about you know Conor
McGregor not me there'll always be
another Conor there'll be another run
that there would have been another
Michael base it was who was in your
opinion the next guy who can who can
carry the torch from if you do retire
after the next fight oh jeez I don't
know I mean that's I mean Darren sells
getting a lot of you know he looks
[__] good and yes I guess Cerrone
looked amazing that was talks the top as
well does he super cocky yeah he's got
the banter
yeah I don't know I'm gonna have to go
obviously not in the UFC you got Michael
venom page yeah he's [__] ridiculous
I mean right now a ton of great fighters
you know and I was the first champ but I
honestly don't believe I'll be the last
so you know I'm at the point to see who
it is that first is really critical or
isn't it like that's yeah that sort of
opens door and I understand what you
mean by there would have been another
one yeah maybe that other one wouldn't
the won a title and maybe you
that wave do you know I mean yeah sure
sure you know and I appreciate that
again but I guess I guess you put a
little time but the thing is maybe you
can't sit there and think about that
we're gonna make you seven new I never
do I know we've got the youths from UFC
people over here and they think I'm a
[__] pain in the ass yes so much in
common
yes so much you know but honestly I mean
I've worked my ass off I really haven't
he's been a lot of sacrifice and I
travel all the time away from the kids
and stuff but I love it I love it I have
a lucky man I was talking about with
actual tough fair watching it cuz that's
my favorite series for a lot of reasons
I thought about our season three to tour
and Ken were just after recall yeah and
the guy you'd be in the final yeah when
I was researching like for this nah he's
a cop no he's a cop yeah he's on the cop
shows he's not a cop show yeah yeah you
know he's like Dog the Bounty Hunter
yeah yeah have you seen it I've watched
a little bit uh yeah taking on kids and
uh yeah he's a character he's a
character he was a baby was a little
grassy enough really yeah yeah yeah cuz
we were in the house you know it's a
reality TV show you know I mean it's no
secret I like it better here and now and
yeah you know one night bollocks you
know I was pleased to find it up [__]
household and he went in actually told
tee or straight ways that Michael was
drinking last night
yeah earlier knee up and so Tito call me
out like a cop would Ashley yeah yeah
yeah Little Snitch and TL called me out
and this is why you do it you know these
kinds of drills the stuff was punishment
but he made just do it as well for being
a snake yes lovely - Gabby said you
shouldn't have been drinking but you
shouldn't be Gracia up your teammates
[Music]
honey you know you say tit or not now
must be funny because he know you're of
that as well now yes yeah is it a
different sort of chat between you then
yeah it's kind of weird I mean of course
when I gotten the ultimate fire I mean
yeah it's Tito Ortiz man you know you
can sort it when he was the hood for
sure her name in the air you know he was
one of the guys that helped build this
company you know and he was one of the
first mega stars of the UFC so yeah it
was like wow Tito Ortiz and then now we
have the same boxing coach I see him in
the gym here in there and yeah you know
I mean TR it will always be held in high
regard and he always has that level of
Speyer
I was shocked when he beats Anand yeah
me too me too
it was weird I was going on him because
I don't say he did that video it was
like me Todd's the dying wish was for me
and he was chopped and he was like I'm
gonna be a world champion I'm gonna be
to you because he'd beat you in a
wrestling match and then he he sort of
saw it getting really like choked up
about ya gonna be tiro and I think he
went in this so emotional his head was
like yeah maybe maybe yeah because then
he beat rampage as well I mean so I
didn't see that coming because how bad
he did against not you know I thought
well Rampur he's gonna destroy him run
[__] was [__] big now as well as
massive yeah he really used to be quite
poly with him are you so cool them or is
there but unfortunately no no so I used
to be with vibe Wolf's really yeah I
don't really want to talk too much about
that believer because there
but yeah so so so so I left those guys
which as I say I won't go into but I
left them because there was a lot of
stuff I didn't agree with it lots of
going on a lot of money whatever I say I
almost said some stuff yeah anyway so I
left and then you know I think they kind
of poison my mind to rampage God does
what they were telling him because then
all of a sudden rampage didn't like me
and I I don't know what was that but I
know I think they kind of [__] on him as
well so he's not really yeah so he's not
with them even though you obviously
quite a straightforward guy in that
sense like you pretty much say how you
see it sure do you think that's helped
you with people like that
because this industry is now full of
people who are trying to hang on or
trying to take a little off the side or
trying to play it their way yeah as a
fighter you're the commodity that
they're selling sure how's that sort of
helped you do you think yeah yeah it's
weird I mean I added armies yeah I guess
it's helping some ways I think he's
somewhere as it kind of it kind of held
me back in some ways as well yeah a lot
of people delight eyes putting on an act
in this analysis there's no [__] act
a pal yeah there's no rehearsed lines or
anything like that have just off the
cuff are gone with the flow and then
sometimes I look back and I'm like wow
well I did it that world like we were
saying about the podcast I do a podcast
on my [__] we need to delete that
episode you know they made the check
that I would believe you me episode you
love them and yeah yeah I mean you know
it's a gift in a curse yeah do you think
you've always been I mean you were
talking about looking back as a vet and
how you've changed maybe you weren't
[__] talk in this final fight do you see
the same Park for the way that you fight
and where you came from what do you mean
like your style in the ring how do you
see that as evolving you know definitely
I mean I mean so so back in the early
days to be honest II was pretty much
just wild aggression you know I didn't
really know what I was doing that much
you know I did a lot of martial arts but
I did I didn't Japanese Jiu Jitsu okay
pretty much none of that is applicable
it was pretty much Mme no I shouldn't
say that because it is actually a
fantastic martial art a lot of it is
real but still Brazilian no no no so
Japanese Gigi she was like the first
martial art and all other martial arts
would take you from Japanese jiu-jitsu
so judo took the throws karate took the
striking and they just you know took it
to the next level but they're Japanese
jiu-jitsu was the first Brazilian
jiu-jitsu obviously took the groundwork
element and so on and so forth so I kind
of a cannon was an MMA but when I first
started as I say was kind of just fueled
of wild aggression and then as I got you
know further further into my career and
started getting more technical so the
technical side was getting better but
the aggression was getting less and I
guess that comes with also you know
maturing again a little bit older having
a nicer life not struggling you know so
and there because a lot of people said
to me I want to see the old place Peter
you know I want to see you out there
but again wild aggression or being like
my comfort dollar forever you know you
can't follow that I guess the best guys
in the world now you're gonna start
using strategy you're gonna become see
if you're super wild you know you might
do all care get some guys but you've got
to be see I used to try and wind myself
up in the locker room I used to like try
and get as mad as possible and go out
there and 99% of the guys I'll be but
not the best people in the world you've
got to be cool calm and collected you've
got to be in the moment you've got a
you're gonna be composed you're gonna be
you're gonna feel the situation you know
if you're angry you're mad in any walk
of life you're never going to be the
best version of yourself you know remain
doing a pod casts you having to call it
whatever it is if you're [__] mad
you're not gonna be the best moment
where I've lost me [__] or now and I
realize like actually I'd be far better
just yeah yes also in a fight in a fire
fight in front of bloody the world and
you've got but you need to be you need
to be on it you need to I don't the
fight that showed that most of all are
the two fights the first time Henderson
night and the second Dan Henderson fight
he never evolved in my opinion at all he
was saying aha
guy who can who can wrestle but doesn't
really use it yeah and when you fought
in the second time it was so different
and you outclassed them I know you did
land those two big shots seize me after
that everyone Cesare had listened he was
robbed other than those two big shots
and backpedaling for most of the fight
he didn't know any nothing he landed two
big shots that was incredibly [__]
heavy make sure the hoof still other
scars on my face you I lost him in that
fight in my opinion in the first fight
it was you you look like a fish out of
water apart yeah well where would you
know in that fire the first fire Jesus
Christ I'm so over trained it was
ridiculous
because I knew yes Dan Henderson former
Olympian Pride champion you know
knockout artist so I trained like a
maniac and when I say like a maniac I
mean like a [__] maniac and it was
just too much you did look a bit like
Gordon and a bit I was totally amazing I
look like Skeletor look ma come out Wow
look how skinny I was and he was that
bad I went out to Vegas for the last six
weeks something like that and I was
training and twice a day I was running
sprints in the morning and I was so sore
and I'd sores all over my body and my
feet and I get to the gym it did take
about an hour of like bloody madness
before my body would even start like
loosening up and stuff what I should
have done was take a week off and you
know I remember know I've got to do more
I've got to do more got to do more which
is the wrong way to be and Jason Perillo
he always says he has a very good line
it takes confidence to take a day off
now there's a fine line between being
confident and taking the day off cuz you
need the rest and being a lazy bastard
but if you know you're not a lazy
bastard is that no I'm good I don't need
to I'm better than this guy and I'm
gonna take the day off today because I
need the rest I'm gonna have a massage
I'm gonna eat some good food and chill
and I'll kill it tomorrow but it takes
confidence to do that because if you're
if you're lacking in comes that now I've
got to do more I'm gonna do more that's
weakness that is a sign of weakness and
yeah and then that was evident in that
fire you know I know I was over trained
I was emaciated I was weak as hell the
[__] out what word would you put for
that emotion that you are feeling it is
that fear is that
no problemo the fear of losing or it's
always the fear of losing always the
fear of leisure I mean I'm I'm not
afraid of any man you know I'll fight
anyone I know that sounds very barbaric
but it's truthful some truly yeah but
but the fear that everyone has a nun you
know I'm not special the majority of
fight is the fear comes from lesion
you're scared of lesion you're scared of
failing in your chosen endeavor you know
you put you sacrifice so much you go out
in front of the world you want to win of
course if you leave that problem you get
your ass kicked as well so there's that
motivation but we're competitors we want
to win if you lose there's financial
ramifications a lot of the contracts are
set up you know half to show and half to
win so the saddest part is you lose you
get your ass kicked and we'll talk [__]
and you've lost half your paycheck the
first [__] loss with us Rashad Rashad
Evans air which was their highly
controversial split a lot of people
thought I won I did actually I thought
you probably wouldn't that failure be
fair I definitely thought you won the
trail fight to be on a still to be
honest with the vash our fight it was
close it was super close and same with
the chair fight as well no bitterness
that it was a close fight it could have
gone either way you know what I mean how
did you deal with losing the Rashad
fight because that was the first time
was that was it really hard because it
wasn't in a fashion where you will care
with that I took it the complete wrong
way right because even though he was
only only on season 2 and I was season 3
he was he was performing really good
back then he was taking people out this
and I remember I was like it was my
first main event it's firing in New
Jersey and I was like come from there
Bouchard Evans is crazy and for me like
just going through a decisions having a
good fire that felt like a bit to your
mast which is not the attitude you need
to have I was look at it I held it at
you high regard too much respect too
much respect and then afterwards I was
fine you know I never I got home I
realized the [__] also I was too small I
was fine a light heavyweight and what
really sent out home was
day the waves easy the sauna he's
killing himself cutting way I'm saying
the Chinese restaurant eating noodles
and drinking 7up do you know how to read
I'm like okay I'm not making the
sacrifices so that's why I went down to
185 not to do the world too good didn't
it really that was like a real good
moment for you yeah it was but again I
didn't even know what I was doing at the
team I was with back then didn't know
what they were doing so I I like most
people like now I'll cook you know I'm
like 220 right now but I'll cut down to
185 I'll get down to about 200 and I'll
cut the rest in water the day before but
then I was dicing all the way down to
185 so not early fights at 185 you know
I was in college when I was walking
around because I didn't know what the
[__] I was doing you know what I made so
I'd lost a lot of power and stuff like
that now in the in the early advice that
was okay but then against guys at Dan
Henderson you know and then after that
that's when I started cutting weight
properly from Georgia pounds Dan it's a
day the way you know when you fought
done the second time was there a lasting
impression obviously you lost badly
against the first time was it was it
hard going into that fight mentally or
was it more a determination yeah yeah
you know so of course and I always talk
about this so it's it's easy to say I
mean you or with my opponent at a press
conference and talk [__] how you can use
bravado or you can say oh this and that
but you can't lie to yourself and when
you let him bed at night you know you
can't you can't the internal dialogue
you can't lie to yourself there you can
[__] all you want and but it wasn't
[__] you can't that's the thing
husband side totally believed I was
gonna be him and this and that and all
the rest of it but on the day of the
fight all the team had gone off I was
having a nap like I always do I have
breakfast I have a little workout then I
just chill turn the lights off in the
very much I haven't happened forget
about the fight and and I couldn't sleep
and I was thinking [__] last time we did
this I got knocked the [__] I was a bad
knock arm and I'm sure you've seen it
but I had no recollection and what got
on for a couple of days after that fight
you know he scrambled me up pretty good
I
it's like that Dow starts creeping in
you know what I mean and then when I
went to the arena remember the fire was
like 6:00 in the morning when we went to
the arena you know again I was a little
touchy with all the team it was kind of
being bit of a dick you know because
that was nerves you know
and then at one point backstage I just
went I said to realize that ultimately I
have a [__] so worried what's the
worst that's gonna happen I'm gonna lose
won't be the first time probably won't
be the [__] last why am I so wild
[__] and then just plate this way to
do it
then I was all smiles we had a laugh
when out how'd it go fight I was one of
my favorite fight say I [__] love
that fight because you had to dig deep
and you proved that sure you could take
it you could take the [__] heaviest
shots I mean handle is as hard as it
gets as ridiculous people say like when
you even just feel as body or so good
party like we saw stiff 90s yeah he's
like a trainer so we take when you're in
the middle of that fight and you get
dropped by the the big right hand
what's going through your head in order
to get through that moment not again
yeah so I mean I'm doing great I was
waiting I was beating him to the punch I
was in and out I was faster than him at
the edge but you know he's built a
career off that right hand and he claims
me and I went down but I was fine yeah
he hit me and he obviously put me down
but I had totally had my you know my for
the the faculties well yeah I'm a
faculties about me I knew what was going
on I - getting back to Murphy and then
in the second round Sam again I think
with the first round oh he went down he
landed some metal bars and they opened
me up pretty good
and I got back to my feet wipe the blood
off my face and then give him a little
smile you know as I said there's a few
pictures of you just blew it on you like
yeah dog face dude I've got some
pictures on my phone after the dream my
brother in the face is a [__] mess
that's why people people like you and
the haters they show that picture online
and they show I had mrs. or who will
despise that no heat me were two good
shots and he opened me up but you don't
win a 25-minute fire by landing two good
shots you know you fight
the trolls online you've got a bit of
you don't mind that at all they're not
too much these days yeah I used to
because it is it it's weird and I think
this is a human nature people do this
but so you'll be on social media
Instagram Twitter whatever and people
say a lot of nice things and but you
can't respond you'll see oh that's cool
that's cool that's cool but the one
person that says something bad then you
respond to them but why would you give
that in the response I'm not the person
that said hey big fan
they're the ones that deserve a response
but I think you [__] [__] I want
to respond to them but so I try not to
do these days these days I just blocked
them and I used to get Jesus Christ so
much and I mean so you've won people
over yeah these days D I mean my
Instagram timeline it was shocking
there's might in the comments I used to
get and all of them all of them they
were terrible and to be honest now it's
all very very positive stuff do you
might get the odd one here and there but
99% of it's all positive stuff so it
does seem you know maybe I'm just let of
a less of a wanker me so I think that's
one thing yeah because the Americans
don't get our humor a bit so they they
take at the heart a little bit
also coming through the hand or
knockdowns and Rockhold all and all the
things like no one can [__] doubt you
anymore like well there's not really
anything anyone really say I think a lot
of it was as well because obviously you
know when you say I mean I'm sarcastic
just like a lot of English are yeah
that's our sense of humor so when we say
things it gets taken out of context yeah
you know and when you write it up in the
headline obviously the context is in
there and then it sounds terrible but if
you see me say I'm kind of laughing or
winking and smiling and just just having
a crack you know what I'm saying and
then when you do that in a fight of
course I've always been the bad guy and
the English guy find in America that's
the narrative they're always gonna put
forward you know a fair play but then
when I moved out there and I was doing
started doing a lot of work on Fox
Sports
people saw more of me yeah I saw me an
hour a time talking to the fire is
another love they could see was my sense
of humor
I think that really helped as well
people saw a little bit more of me and
realized hold on a minute he's maybe not
such a prick after all
did you put a real you put a lot of
value behind those words because
obviously you have said a lot of stuff
which words the work the words when
you're in the press conference you all
the bravado as you say did you think
that was an important part of your game
at one point no no no that was never
like a conscious decision but if you got
a fight you've gotta be confident that
you gotta wait so all's fair in love and
war is actually oh yeah and if you're
not confident
you gotta lose right you're not gonna
commit you know if you're scared you
throw a punch and you're not committing
you know stepping into all that stuff
and if you believe you gonna win you're
gonna say it and and there's a lot of
strategy to it like on the waves people
always said that I get in people's faces
you can win a fight on the scale you
know you can get into Europe on its face
and you can say you let it on the [__]
tomorrow it is [__] on we were
[__] on three one sake [__] online
but tomorrow I'm gonna smash your
[__] face in about and they're like
and then you see sometimes in their eyes
of that all of them all of them some
people laugh at me do you know what I
mean but someone can break perform the
next day we've got a guy we went with
who once said like a fun faceoff with
you right and he said honestly he said
he's not fighting guys a normal guy and
yeah yeah it was like when you look into
the eyes of like a drug and I actually
fought like [__] yeah
one of the things that you've done in
poetry I remember now watch you are on
the panel when McGregor just be yep and
I watch that back and you and you
McGregor were like Bundoran you're like
oh yeah yeah yeah and somewhere along
the way and I don't know if there's a
moment that's happened and you might not
want to talk let's not respect that yeah
we could edit this out no it's fine it's
fine
is there a moment that happened because
I know that you guys have a relation you
know it's just a shame really
it is a shame and listen I'm a big fan
of Conor McGregor I love the way he
fights
I think he's awesome I think he's the
most exciting fire in the game you know
and I love his bounces he's hilarious
and as I say I'm good for him I'm not
being a hater here [__] goblins like
a lot of guys yeah I'll be honest so
water so he went for the xxx movie
really was doing that and then he got
beat up Nate Diaz and he and he didn't
you know he turned the role down but so
then my agent got me the audition for it
and there was like five actors went for
it and I got the part
yeah I wasn't given it I tried to
audition and then he did a press
conference and a journalist asked him
about it said you regret not doing that
[__] we did it and then won the tile
and he said oh to be honest [__] she
knows me a percentage of his money I
handed that to him on a silver platter
and this and then yeah and I didn't even
get a thank you I said I kind of pissed
me off a little bit sold on a minute
you've got enough going on in your life
without berating my accomplishments so
all I did was I had a radio show back
that on Sirius XM and the idea the
álvarez fire coming up and I predicted
that Eddie Alvarez would be him to be us
didn't even really believe that but I
was like [__] him I'm gonna do a favor
so I said I always will be him on each
of offense tonight and then we went back
and forth you know a few messages here
and there then that was that I wish it
the best do you think will soon Bach in
the yeah for sure for sure absolutely we
have to say manager you say alright yeah
yeah we have to say manager I yeah I
don't know for sure he's coming back
yeah yeah
no it's called audio tired and sports
management
yeah and you know Connors awesome man I
love you know no one misses it McGregor
fight you know he's the man he really is
he's incredible to watch hilarious you
know he's unpredictable he's wild about
my mother coming to the UFC ya bollix
it's after a chair Walters I know Tara
Woodley says that he's trading him so
you you've got quite a good relationship
would lead you right knees bullshitting
yeah I don't know I don't know he said
it yeah
and I don't think times I was not the
type of person going out there telling
lies yeah so I don't know maybe there is
some truth to a Bob I think yeah I just
I just who would you put him again read
into that what you willing Tyler says
he's training him and I think that you
know it's gonna be a lot of buddy so I
signed the contract you're saying why
not I'm wired up do you know what I mean
I guess if I was him I wouldn't do it
loses so what he's not an MMA guy that
he's been paired a ton of money and he
said at least I had the balls to try it
and his boxing record would still be
attacked exactly so so I guess when you
put it like that maybe to make that
shift though isn't it I imagine it's
well you know people said it would be
easier for good to go one way rather
than the other but for him he's just
been upper body his entire life he's
absolutely and you know about the rest
do you do you think that would be
something that he could do like is that
that's gonna take a lot ya know it does
take a long time but to be fair I mean
number way he's got the box you know
already you know if it'll nose him tear
down the fence learn how to defensive
kicks
that's what Woodley was saying he
worried you know six months he could
have a grasp with some of the basics and
if they matched him up right they gave
him a striking that can't tear people
down
you've got to favor him in that you know
part of my kickin with me whether I
think his boxing style so if you look at
all the different box and styles his
style is probably the worst
style for MMA and I say that because he
relies on a club sighs yeah now for
Charlene's back which is like worst
thing to do for a takedown I just think
it open you're right but he's also
incredibly hard to hit he's very very
elusive you know and a lot of that is
gonna get away with that he'd ever made
what but you know he's not an idiot he
will recognize Daniel evolved it a
little bit but he's had movement he's
amazing his foot works amazingly speed
his reflexes all that stuff I'd love to
see Connor and him fight he imagined
listen the box you know Floyd Mayweather
compared to a boxer a guy that likes to
box in the UFC he's gonna be there's no
comparison if the Concord into the floor
other than some kicks I think they gonna
have a hard time but if he fought Connor
in the UFC kind of will wipe the floor
with him hands down it was that she's a
now saying that I said that the Nate
Diaz fight the first one remember II
took it on short notice Diaz and that
was the week after I fought Anderson
Silva and they're so old and that broke
that week and all the staff so that all
the journalists were like oh Diaz
McGregor what's your prediction I said I
guarantee McGregor is going to kill it
myself
he got a ton home on one of the news
guys ended up having to get Nate Diaz
that's right the commentator do you
remember your first time in the Octagon
and how that felt because that must have
been big moment for you yeah well I mean
that was on the orbit fighter you know
but so yeah so but yeah that was yeah
yeah it was good man what we like do you
remember the emotion that you had going
in there was that proud moment for you
or was that I don't know no I wouldn't
say proud I mean but back then I was
still on both journey to trying to
provide from the families and that be
every like if the goal posts were always
moving
it was our Kerrigan I got to get my
first fight with a shining somebody and
then and then I fall for the kgstiles I
want to win this then I got I went on
the ultimate fire and then I've got to
win this fight on the open fire
otherwise I'm not gonna win the show and
then you get to the fiery level I've got
to win the [__] final because it's
the whole point of it
now and then it's like now I'm in the
UFC I've gotta win cuz I want to stay
here so the goal posts are always moving
you know so so yeah you know it was
always yeah great
you know I'm here but it never felt oh
I'm here I've done it but Eve did start
there's always the next thing to achieve
an energy main event you know now we're
getting the more content there then you
find for the bell you know so it's
always movies you can never stop your
son is quite a profession american-style
Russell yes I'm really impressed with
him he's winning competitions our friend
son that's yeah he's ridiculous are you
hopping want him to go on the family
business
oh no no no he's a really good kid you
know he's I couldn't be prouder but
y'all get obviously you love him but
he's captain of the wrestling team and
wrestles at 195
he won League he would the county he
went to CIF which is like you know the
California story he won that then he
went to what's called masters came
second or something in masters and then
he qualified for the state finals so you
know the best wrestlers in the whole of
California and they placed there as well
and he's only a Julius or the guys you
know they're all seniors which is
they're 18 he's only 16 well and you
know any place there as well so and so
ironic cuz your weakness when you yes it
was wrestling know for sure now we're
never exposed to it though I don't
really have wrestling I mean we do have
it in the UK a little bit but you've
really got to find it its niche you know
but he does it a school and he has a
tremendous team and yes amazing it
really is I'm so proud of him do you
have a contrast your upbringing and then
think about what he has yeah and that's
you know he doesn't I mean he could do
it when he goes out there wrestles
people's heads off but so he could do
and I think to me as I mentioned was it
yeah for sure yeah we do because I take
him on the pads that stuff like that he
used to do to Jitsu now he doesn't have
time because wrestling is that full-time
to think the trade three hours a day the
lift weights in the morning it's
incredible to schedule they have to keep
part of me but we've spoke about it and
I think maybe it like to have one or two
just to say did it you know what I'm
saying but not to make a career out of
it if you
wanted to do that ad-supported might
that support me but why that also beat
the [__] out of me on a daily basis and
my mom and my brothers you know violence
in my house growing army you've got no
idea a lot of extreme violence so this
symposium brothers always end up as
fight with John John's class yeah yeah
so so obviously that that kind of led me
you know getting your ass kicked every
day you gotta kind of get used to it
let's go up in though because that it's
not my household when I was probably
tell but like how we did that did that
shape you do you think were you nervous
or is that just something became normal
at the time suture be honest all that
ever experience was violence you know to
me so so I thought it was totally normal
that's why I used to get so many fights
as a kid you know out of me because I
just you know that's all I'd ever seen
you know and I love my mom and dad and
yeah very much so but you know growing
up my dad was an angry man he came out
the army he was a sniper in the army
care man just thrown on the scrappy
looking back now obviously had
depression and maybe who knows Ramon yes
yeah maybe all kinds of [__] going on
you know I you know but what was the
question
just that growing up in a what you call
a violent house do you think that that
had some contribute in fact is the
character you yeah absolutely because as
I say I mean that that's kind of all
I've ever experienced so I thought it
was totally novels they forgot to an
argument to turn it into a fight and
then I met my wife fortunately and she's
an amazing woman and she's in training
shoe [__] right she did yeah of
course what I should be I should be you
know an emotional wreck you know
probably still am but I was a lot better
did you meet you're quite young yeah it
would be together 19 years laughs okay
yeah yeah have you maintained a
successful relationship like that with
all their because let's be honest yeah
you get a lot of success and that women
come with that and yeah not really I
mean I think so so my mate he has an
expression for what I have and what you
know majority of MMA fighters are
because the OBS
opposite be boosts in Europe you know
it's
women really sweaty dudes be all right
that's it that's - you like tramps us in
the corner I'd love it if it was like
just you know good lucky girls but you
know generally yeah OBS that's because
it which is hilarious but he did say yes
I've seen to me a home movies and I
thought was funny as that one your
littlest blood he's got such cheek on
him like he's always I love him daily
he's hilarious funny look he he was life
or on the phone house I love you silent
yeah al said he won't give me a same
won't give me a kiss my mama's boy oh my
god Omar Jenni as I saw well I'm going
away I've been away for almost two weeks
now
he said yes I get sleep in your bed
every day he's not bothered I call him
he doesn't want to talk
but he's hilarious he won't get he as I
say bye like every soul stubborn he's
he's just like me the older too you know
of cost of my children but they're very
much like the mother they're very very
calm very soon my losses the very
mild-mannered you know which is great
but Lucas is a [__] maniac right and
of what I feel he's paying I'm saying
yeah because you describe yourself as a
kid like sort of relentless energy and
you know it's a bit like that 100% what
net doesn't stop and that's what you
were told you kind of like oh god we
might have a right deal on my hands oh
no no because you know he's actually
he's very sensitive you know he's a good
kid but ya know yeah but I love it I
love it you know I wouldn't change it
for the world
what are you like as a tot you think you
do you think you're quite sensitive to
their needs and you think about things
more than your parents might return yeah
1 million percent you know I mean I
pride myself on being a good father I
love them dearly I do everything economy
they just be there this is all for that
you know what I mean there's a you know
last week good but I'm not spending it
and an acting flash you know what I mean
it's all for the kids yeah yeah don't
very hands-on love them daily I mean
they've got a beautiful mother and she
she's dedicated her life to the children
fortunately you know I do this and she's
in a position to be able to
do that but ya know we have a really
really close family you bigger growing
up in the States
I'm yeah we've been there for six years
so yeah the older two they've still got
their English accents when they speak to
was but when the talking to the friends
who are these people and then but Lucas
obviously he was Yves only one when we
moved there so he's fallen American
Californian yeah yeah but which is
accent so cute because I was we're not
used to it to anyone in America is just
the typical kid but we think it's so
cute of course you know as parents you
think your kids the cutest or whatever
but ellie my daughter she was a friend
was in the car and she forgot on a phone
or something like that yeah and she
forgot to speak in her American accent
and her friend was in the car they've
been friends for years and she says I
forgot before oh and joy oh my god
if you got an English accent because she
never heard of speak English but she
just wants to fit in as a you know a
teenager yeah so yeah yeah that was
funny that's kind of a cool commodity
though like if you're an English person
in America you're like a you know you're
a rare thing
there must be something that's quite
good because maybe you know a challenge
around LA there's a lot of English
people yes yeah yeah it's not
necessarily a good thing yeah love the
average now yeah they do
we've got absolute questions from
Twitter okay fire away have you read
boxing Anthony Joshua Wilder Tyson Fury
over those three who ends up the king I
would have a long time ago said under
the Joshua for sure because I wasn't a
fan of Tyson Fury right but honestly I
think he beats them all even if he gets
in shape but now I was a fan of Tyson
Fury we had a little back and forth a
you gotta [__] fall for someone yeah
exactly
no but it's crazy I know shocking
laughter he is not type of car
well he went round there telling
everybody and putting it on social media
that is made gypsy John whoever the [__]
he is knocked me out outside a nightclub
recently how's that alright that's good
you do realize I live in California so I
don't know how he knocked me out in this
nightclub close to my hometown but
whatever yeah gypsy drunk traveler there
you go so you know we went back and
forth a little bit you know whatever
wasn't very pleasant so I was like yeah
you know he's a [__] yada yada yeah
but his fight against Klitschko listen
he's not pretty to look at and his
Styles not the prettiest but he was very
very effective his jabs his work rate
he's faced his face is what wanting that
fight to save these intelligences yeah
yeah he knows what he's doing he really
does so so what once I got past that
because that was clouding my judgment a
little bit and now actually I'm a fan of
his I'm a fan I like the way just listen
he's been a [__] in the past you
know but well lately I think he's doing
himself a lot of favors to raise Karin
himself lately on Instagram for this
comeback yeah yeah yeah and he's looking
good you know and I think he's I think
he's you know but short or whatever
farmy for me to say that I'm not I'm not
condescending him I'm saying it I see a
different side these days he's what I'm
trying to see say and yeah I think I
think you'll give Joshua problems Wilder
why do you think he gives Josh isn't
Joshua's a little bit too basic sauce
it's pretty kind of his basis yeah I
mean I'm not taking anything away I'm a
big fan of his [__] good about basics
Ken he's amazing the big unit and he
hits hard and he's got a good chin and
on aluminium he's great all those things
about him off cameras I'm a huge fan of
a Denis Joshua I just think we've fuse
ranges reach is what's going to give a
lot of people that he knows how to use
that reach so and welcome wild wild what
you never know because he's kind of
sloppy but Sussie his hog
so yeah I mean I don't know I don't know
oh you can make an argument for all
three of them to be honest fury might be
your pip yeah sounds crazy to say I
don't know if I put money on it I'd say
Joshua well when you auntie the Joshua
really impressed me when he fought
Klitschko yeah next morning you know he
was on Instagram he was having a
recovery swim and this and that had a
fall
this guy's a consummate professional
after find me the next day I'm [__]
nowhere near Egypt let's just say that
you know if anything I kind of like the
fact that fury as a bit broken I kind of
identify more sure there's a bit of a
[__] right because I like seeing
someone come back from where as to me
Joshua I respect that he's a constant
professional but it's almost like he's
just too perfect almost yeah this one
he's like he's not watching the scene
struggling there gets wheeled out for
sure you know he's chiseled EJC table
looks like a [__] model dose of a
kind of rather roof or sort of yeah yeah
yeah you can easily like in Shrek I saw
you solving the oh yeah so when it comes
down to people like Tyson Fury and
you're looking at people who are maybe
not a similar character to you but
people who are treading a similar path
in their career as what you put yourself
a veteran now do you sort of see see
what they're doing you you were talking
about you know the way that those sort
of things you see the same mistakes that
you made in think no no not at all not
in fact quite the opposite I'm say just
lately I feel he's coming across really
well on the video stuff that he puts on
Instagram yeah I think he's been really
real and I think he's be really humble I
know that's why I'm that's why I said
I've come around to him I've even
commented on his stuff a couple of times
after I said we had a little back and
forth he probably doesn't even remember
it you know what I made so a few good
notes out since yeah yeah exactly yeah
but you know and I like what I saved you
don't really
also without someone asked who's your
favorite fighter to watch whether it be
any sports it's really like you asked
her all the time
another one is that who was your
inspiration yeah and there was no one
you know I never got into this because I
looked at someone on TV and I thought I
want to do that I want to be like this
fighter or whatever I did it because I
wanted to provide from her family simple
as that favorite fire so watch I mean
it's hard to narrow it down
I mean back in the day and this is
silver when he wasn't [__] around and
being boring when he turned the art for
sure he was one of Forrest Griffin
fights Don Soffer
yeah he was incredible like I'll tell
you I like Cordy go operand I know he
lost his loss yeah yeah yeah yeah he'd
know called in that final season
everyone's out of is about 4 foot by
after the last fight you bump into each
other and as the older guy and he's sort
of the younger guy yeah yeah so I give
him a bit of advice I look mate you'll
be back yeah thank you thank you yes I
like coeliac I remember what happened he
said it was even they said something it
was silly right you know I think I said
btj the real main event that's what he
said right now if you look at the
posters mate and I'm definitely coming
in last you know I like his style I
think he's got ya know he is he's great
he's great do you end up bumping into a
lot of fighters like that I don't like I
don't like people last without who you
friends you never made this and that I
really haven't it to be honest honestly
when I'm not doing all this type of
stuff I am a very boring person and I've
just that hob with the kids you know
very very yeah I just tell home of the
kids all the time that's all I do we
don't go out you know I'm not out
partying and doing that type of stuff
you know you know now you know when I'm
traveling whatever I might have the odd
night ear in there but at all I never go
out you know and I don't drink a lot you
know nobody get when I'm traveling of
course you you're away and you end up
with the boys in this and that is that
kind of apples but generally I'm not a
drinking these days
and I'm just at home with the kids and
just just doing boring [__] walking the
dogs cooking a steak you know Instagram
is I'm happy as long as I love it that's
not know of a place I'd rather be
cook the quick picks for us see fights
coming up roars thud roars versus
Johanna aah
you know I've gotta go with Rose I gotta
go we want us to easy hit you know well
I like your Jay check I do that she's a
sweetheart and that you know she she put
some you know a good show or whatever
but she's a really nice girl when you
meet her so and I wish you the best
I just think now Eunice has got
something you know I just it's hard yeah
it's hard and she's in a prime now you
know I feel she's gone to the next level
she's coming in there with obviously she
knocked her out first round last time
that's gonna give her a world of
confidence Jake's not used to dealing
with that she might come back and bounce
back and improve you know that she's got
it and I is the test of a real fighter
come back after getting knocked out so
we'll see but yeah I'd put my money on
rounds Ferguson versus could be yeah
that's the tricky one for me to pick
because you know Ferguson we have the
same manager as well and I like Tony you
know he's down in Orange County also so
I see him about Tony could pull it off
but I can also I can easily see a path
of a victory for could be and I base
that on Kevin Lee when he fought Tony
Ferguson that was what put the dots in
my him in the first round he had him
mounted and nearly finished him he was
kind of Saved by the Bell
and if Kevin Lee can do that I fought me
so they're calling O'Connor Lee's lon
and that left to gay if Kevin Lee can do
that Tony damn sure khabib can but but
Tony's so unorthodox you know you never
know what he'll out of the bag so
honestly I don't know
dr. Jitsu hopefully will help him if he
does because he's going to the ground
yeah he's getting take it down for sure
see see versus steep me I know you're
quite poly with DC yeah DC's awesome
searching it's such a good date he
really is and I've got one for taking
this photo oh dude why wouldn't you
nothing to lose I'm gonna get parish it
to the money and he can become a true
legend like everywhere and heavyweight
champion at the same time incredible
he's capable of it as well as like he's
definitely capable of it I mean look
what he did it's Triforce the
Strikeforce Grand Prix he was undefeated
as a heavyweight and I've got so much
respect for that and he's such a good
guy he really is but I I just think
Steve has got the advantages he muscled
himself he's the bigger guy he probably
hits harder he's the taller guy he's got
the rain didn't look great in my opinion
against and gone who like although you
beaten gone who I formed myself like and
I know it's he's right but look at what
and God who did to everybody else yeah
it's like you didn't look his best
version of himself
Eva yeah Ross Pearson - you know if this
happens as in if you fight in London
soon I in England so yeah I want to be a
part of that I started my UFC career
through Mike and I want to be there on
his fire good relationship with him yeah
yeah Ross is awesome Russ is a you know
I got so much respect for us Ross he's
like a proper fire yes Russ is a real
fire and I think nobody's with similar
backgrounds you know it'll be
working-class guy worked hard with China
you know make it go alive you know and I
think he's under road massive well said
the potential to be champion yes I
thought that especially when he was
really on the club yeah yeah you know
it's a tough game oh yeah you know
anyone's capable be champion you know in
the top 10 on a good day anyone could be
anyone you know but you know
he had a bad one recently that's the way
it goes man
you know you get caught you started
taking knockouts you take mileage and
this and that he's not no he's not done
so we've got two questions
okay for the UFC game and then I've got
one final question okay we've been
talking a lot about UFC three on this
podcast and one of the biggest changes
is the introduction to building your
profile outside the Octagon as you can
see this fits in perfectly you're a
master of this how important is it is
this in developing a successful career
in UFC because what is the role
character in a program outside outside
the Octagon well yeah primarily the fans
got to do the talking you know yeah you
could be the best [__] talker you can be
good-looking you can do this you can be
a model you can do whatever it is but if
you give you if you can't win your
fights you can't win your fires that's
first and foremost
you can be a model just saw salute Raul
yeah exactly exactly
witty face is the most important thing I
need any of you you know whatever your
personality is just go with that you
know if you go out there fight great you
want you want it at the weigh-in
sometimes yes question two when you
start out your career in UFC three your
scrimping and saving
this is relatable where you can
potentially working we where you can
potentially working out in your own home
and doing anything that you can to get
by can you recall what training was like
in your early career even though we kind
of yeah was it hard Mike it was very
hard really hard so hard it must have
been tricky initially because you
actually want me to answer probably
don't you said you're out of shape of it
yeah but yeah there's some pictures of
me when I was younger I did I was I was
a bit of a fat bastard
you know only for a little period down
for a little period I was working at
this this factory as an upholsterer and
just eating [__] just eat he [__] and
then I everywhere start called me a fat
bastard oh you fight about sighs I know
I'm not a fat bastard I'm just big you
know I'm just big I'm just big and I
serve all the time yeah I remember
I remember the day I made the change I
got out of the bath I've had this big
mirror I had the box and as I stood up
and I'll glance to the left and I caught
me on refresh you know and I was like
wow so we're so yeah that's where they
all changed yeah so I like that and
every podcast with one question how
would you like to be remembered
yeah I would like to be remembered I
don't know it's a tough one you know I
mean I don't like to disappear my own
[__] but I mean to be honest I mean
if I could do it anyone can do it you
just got show a bit of hard work
determination really good look The Good
Wife bit of support anyone could achieve
it you know yes you know and I don't
know I don't know I mean I never took
steroids you know a lot of people do
I've done it through blood sweat and
tears hard work you know yeah I always
try to bring it bring a bit a vegetarian
I don't know we'll see we'll see what
people said that's not for me to say
well thanks very much mit is great
really good Chargers I sinned conceived
believe achieve shut the [__] up